today I'd someone get let you guys know
that um I went into work today for the
ekend season nice and I'm sitting I once
I walk in the guy Dean was guy named
Dean Holland who is the reason why I'm
on the show cuz he worked at love he
brought me over he goes in come in here
and that I he we walk in the room and
guess who the hired as a producer you're
not gonna know I'm gonna tell you a guy
by the name of Scott sights Scott Seitz
was my producer at MADtv for eight years
Scott Seitz was there at the
intervention when I was on drugs
Scott Seitz was there when I [ __ ] in big
blue cheese office he saw he was there
when I [ __ ] in Ike Barinholtz
dressing room he was there when I farted
in krysta Flanagan's mouth this guy was
in every single important moment in your
life no because he was the guy to call
me or put me in his office and go Bobby
why did you do that he was that guy so
I've left some when I saw him obviously
the hug was deep I love this dude he's
my friend
and he was my boss so then we sit down
with Dean and now let me just say this
okay
when I was on MADtv I was a nightmare
like I'll give you an example we were
sponsored by Yaris in the car yet the
tiny car is Toyota Toyota Yaris
so what mad tv would make us do is you
know if we wrote a sketch or whatever
they go you won't you're gonna have to
stay to go to your us in the sketch I'm
like all right I will but do we get any
money [ __ ] no we're getting the money
oh right so arm we had got to go a Betty
you want to go on a date in my Toyota
Yaris Wayne wink wink it was like
terrible so a couple of weeks later I
was just fed up with it and we had one
Toyota Yaris that we used in every
sketch that's so weird
I stole the keys the key Toyota Yaris
and I had Jordan Peele and Ike
Barinholtz come in the car
let's go for a joyride they took it down
an alley and I scraped it against a
[ __ ] alley wall yeah and I did six
thousand dollars of damage underneath
the car and I brought it back and it was
like the thing was falling apart that's
how crazy I was and I parked and I go
there you go and they were like all just
I couldn't believe it
my behavior do you get fired oh because
I do it I did it because I didn't fire
me you can't do it in the beginning yeah
in the beginning a fire you heard that
but you know we do you know where you're
in any job testing boundaries where you
go this yeah I can do this it was not
good but so Scott saw that right jeez
hey so now we're sitting down with this
now now when I'm on splitting up I am on
time for that one except for that one
time I was late I'm on time I'm you know
I'm cordial I know everyone's name I'm
so nice I don't fart in anyone's mouth
I haven't [ __ ] on anyone's floor I
haven't crashed in a [ __ ] car I'm like
people think I'm a Christian there yeah
god bless you have a fruitful day I say
[ __ ] like that have a fruitful yeah they
go what they go he also put his hand on
my chest I said good it's the $20 yeah
and then so we sit down with this guy
Dean and then Scott goes oh my god I
gotta tell you this one thing that he
did and I go stop I had to yell back
stop
and I told they don't know they don't
know that he said I know but he took his
I go you can't say that he wasn't he
took his dick out and peed on somebody
or whatever right and I wanted and then
and then Dean goes I know that oh yeah
that's how he used to be but he's not
like that here which is great but um it
could be bad I mean he could get drunk
with them be like tell all the stories
and tell the stories but you know if I'm
not like that now right that's gonna
affect me a man can change right a man
can improve and and realize his past
you know aggression a transgression
right questions
[Music]